all morning we've been talking about
Super Tuesday people in 14 states today
and a u.s. territory will vote and it
could be a defining day in the
Democratic presidential race the
remaining candidates Bernie Sanders Joe
Biden Elizabeth Warren Mike Bloomberg
and Tulsi Gabbard are going after more
than 1300 convention delegates that as
we've been saying all morning is more
than a third of all the regular
delegates who will help decide the
party's nominee in July in Milwaukee
voters are already lining up at polling
stations this morning this one's in
Charlottesville Virginia joining us now
to chew it all over Valerie Jarrett
former senior adviser to President Obama
and CBS News political contributor Jamal
Simmons they're going to talk about
what's at stake today good morning to
both of you all over let's chew it over
let's start with you I mean what's your
reaction to this triple endorsement that
Joe Biden picked up overnight huge shot
in the arm he had a great victory in
South Carolina I think to have his
opponents so quickly line up behind him
is a great great sense of momentum that
he has going into Super Tuesday but I'll
tell you what I think I think that
whoever emerges tonight particularly if
it's Bernie Sanders if it's Vice
President Biden or even if it's Mayor
Bloomberg what I would do is break with
conventional wisdom and announce a
running mate it's a woman of color no
not tonight maybe before certainly
before the next primary yeah interesting
woman person of color someone who
reflects the diversity of our party and
yeah that's not usual that's not what
they normally do but these are not
normal times and I think it would send a
very important signal going into the
next round of primaries to do so with a
running mate you see a team of rivals
perhaps I think a dream that builds a
big tent that's one of the strengths of
our party and I think what we what we
know is that you can't just win on a
narrow base and so I would look at ways
of building a broader tent with an eye
towards the general election the reason
why Barack Obama won not once but twice
he had progressives moderates
independents and some Republicans and
that's what we're going to need in the
general it's interesting you say that
because Tom Friedman had a great article
in The New York Times recently where he
said that very thing pick a team of
rivals and you could go to victory I
thought it was interesting it's a really
good read Jamal let's talk about Mayor
Bloomberg tonight sure because he's put
out really all his eggs in the basket
for this thing tonight what needs to
have
than for him if he doesn't do well what
happens he's gotta win delegates I mean
like you said he'd been over 400 million
dollars he can't come out of that with
goose eggs so he's got to find a way to
win some delegates to prove to people
that money was well spent
he's got a lot of Delegates people are
talking about him that's not a win
States does he have to stay I'm not
convinced he has to win a state you know
he second place works you know again
this is a delegate fight so he's got to
have enough delegates and he's a
credible candidate for the White House
and if he's not really winning enough
delegates what's he doing what he's
still in it a court in Europe in your
mind because it seems everyone's talking
about Bernie and Biden his bloomberg
still in it no the rationale for the
Bloomberg campaign was that Joe Biden
would be falling apart by this point it
wouldn't be working that's not happening
Joe Biden's getting stronger he seems to
be growing so the question now becomes
whether or not we ought to have a Mike
Bloomberg still there in this campaign
and why the Democrats are struggling
here Joe Biden has had a line has been
using about Democrats want a real
Democrat or proud Democrat that's
running for presidents represent the
party there are people who do want that
and on the other hand you've got Bernie
Sanders who's running a campaign that
seems to be fighting not just the
Republicans but also the traditional
democratic party elected officials you
know a lot of the Bernie bros online
I've been learning after
african-americans in South Carolina Ava
Duvernay even had any notes took on some
water from some of this crowd Bernie
Sanders has to decide is he more
interested in beating Donald Trump or
more interested in beating traditional
he's leading in Texas and California in
California substantially two biggest
states almost half the delegates today
what do you think is gonna happen oh I
would expect Bernie Sanders would get to
win California again let's pay attention
to the margins is he growing his
population is he bringing in these new
voters that he's been talking about and
growing that number also is he or is he
winning over some of the traditional
Democrats when he's invited last night
he him this is a good line he invited an
Amy Klobuchar and P boudoir judges
campaign supporters to come and join him
if that's happening then they'll see
Bernie Sanders grows coalition and
that's the path to victory not fighting
traditional Valeri we have to pay
attention to Bernie Sanders supporters
do we not because we're speaking very
loudly not only are they loud but they
vote they turn out they have a lot of
energy and so yes I think but that's
that's kind of my point we need a big
ten week
leave anybody behind if we actually want
to win in November and that's the eye on
the prize I think that's where Mayor
Bloomberg that's why he got in the race
he was worried about President Trump he
was worried was there somebody viable in
the field and so I think all of them are
gonna eventually pull ranks and focus on
how to build a big tent so that we can
win in November
Elizabeth Warren Valerie do you think
there's a path so for her I wouldn't
write her out look the last time I was
here everybody was discounting Vice
President Biden so she is a force of
nature she's a good campaigner she's a
strong strong candidate
it's important that she have a good
night tonight all right thank you both
thank you come back and chew anytime
this story has many legs Valerie Jarrett
and Jamal Simmons always welcome